[Music]
good that's my name well cos a Google
forest thing this game is fighting you
released 2012 got some pretty dope
graphics going on Benedict let's go
this is a mod of doom - don't even know
how to walk forward in backwards South
Africa you work with arrows things that
is my face down there do you see the
similarities alright so that is fire I
can't look up and down in doing which is
pretty dope we don't need to look up and
down and doing because what's up and
down is not departed that it's kind of
pissing me off there but whatever let's
go whoa
what the [ __ ] is that I got spooked by
yes jazz I didn't even see what killed
me oh okay
are we back as you shoot my arrow I shot
your with my our I don't even know what
the [ __ ] happened oh hello tree how you
doing Oh another tree what is this
oh I'm in a forest and Google for us all
right bring it [ __ ] [ __ ] be
snitching like snitches diamino forest
with manera bow bow thingy and that's
okay and I knew nish
this is totally what I would be doing if
I'm in the fire
I died in two seconds I don't even know
how whoa what the [ __ ]
back off what the [ __ ] why would he eat
me that name
there any directions on how to believe I
don't the bladers anymore I don't see
anything not a plant happening
you're [ __ ] I know I'm [ __ ] but I'm
doing this oh wow it's another fire oh
no its fire that we started with isn't
that fantastic let's follow this alright
and see what happens
with tabatha in the forest late at night
stay then this war is late at night
that's what my momma always said and she
spanked me I don't know why she did it
alright my trees I suppose I wonder if
this game has any objective already can
co-op it I see something over there
well Oh cancer you look like Super Mario
I shoot you an arrow well you picked up
an arrow I picked up my own hey I shoot
you and you give me arrow isn't that
lovely
alright so what do we do it is there any
understood oh I can shoot we control
fantastic
[Music]
all right let's see what lies beyond
there things of Narnia someone
whispering [ __ ] this [ __ ] [ __ ]
Oh [ __ ] Oh
[Music]
I don't know if I want to do this again
college Kruger's everywhere
alright that's cool walking on the plank
whoa Lance what are you doing gun scare
Midland hey [ __ ] I know I'm [ __ ] not
have been [ __ ] twice it's gonna be
like two minutes alright
oh hello chop tree you speak Japanese
you get that joke no I don't get it
either that [ __ ] thing
he just it's so creepy because I barely
saw it and then is this [ __ ] up in my
[ __ ] well not actually my [ __ ]
okay it's totally see no no no now I
have about you see that see how bout it
goes right in your mom's vagina
alright it's pretty cool stuff how's
everyone doing in here
it's not [ __ ] funny if you'd be uh
what is this I don't get it I don't get
it I don't
Yannick atanga one of these bidets
brush-like in a year or so I'll be
sitting here playing one of these games
and it won't end good I should get a
life insurance big fat life insurance so
once I get that heart attack I know it
why does it disappear like that I don't
get it
you're [ __ ] pity I know I missed a
plant say no it's not my fault but I
couldn't choose to continue anyway oh oh
oh I get it
we're not supposed to use the mouse I
get it and I should with control all
right I feel better now all right
actually I like the mouse cos you know I
can look around and stuff I say yeah a
chop all right I didn't see any I say
Mara reckoning scare you anymore right
what what what I don't even say [ __ ]
skulls man [ __ ] skulls of skull enos
Scully
no Scully would never do that it must be
a zeal trend makes no sense I may ignore
Sanj hater bottom ignore that let's
restart this [ __ ]
hey Caramba I seen ya
this game was a [ __ ] to even installed
it's a [ __ ] now as well and it will be
a [ __ ] once I stopped playing because I
will have nightmares which Etzel on my
central dancer
yes that's the objective of this game
don't get [ __ ] nightmares alright
let's choose a little simpler infinity
that must be easier right all right
I am the easiest level now it can't go
wrong I'd want to kill something at
least they should have farther I shoot
that that makes no sense I saw it going
to infinity another tree hello oh wow
did I walk in circles no I didn't have
found another camera stop telling me I'm
[ __ ] the right start bunny hello
everyone doing back in the forest I
suppose sorry I had something in my
mouth hey watch it dear I'm standing my
ground here energy quick up oh no it
doesn't work that way desert
does not work that way I hear some
whispering kena no no no no it's long
ago whoa [ __ ] you I shot you I shot your
mama
no I didn't but I should alright okay
you just gotta know where they come from
you just gotta know are you sure this
killer isn't even remotely fat no no no
okay going here in the snow there's no
snow what are you talking about there's
snow everywhere I [ __ ] you with a shoe
last night you did Oh No
how about you with the shoot I do with
the show how about you wither shoe [ __ ]
I [ __ ] you with a shoe an arrow shot you
with the boom
ain't no can fool I shot you with your
shoe alright there's a ball that means I
can nothing doesn't mean oh where it's
sharper there and then bet oh gosh haha
I invent my own language like seriously
what the hell is this [ __ ] go in my own
mouth what no I don't why would you say
that it probably takes donations
disgusting I always get those two mixed
up let's see if we can actually pass as
far as with that passing out
that makes sense okay I got it arrow
load lock and loaded pick back up no no
I don't like it I don't like your
attitude
hey [ __ ] it I can't do this browse by
alright if you have played this god
bless you actually but if anyone
actually finished this holy sugar sign
everywhere I might give it another try
tomorrow let's say right now I just want
to play something that has rainbows in
it so that's pretty much it for it yeah
[Applause]
that's what a lame egg mulai it's
America
I love that all right there we go whoa
whoa